hey leute
wenn ich mal wieder einen tag bei meinen
großeltern bin dann weiß ich immer
abends eines ganz sicher alt werden
macht keinen spaß
man ist nicht mehr so agil und
lebensfroh wie früher viele dinge am
körper tut einem weh und man ist auf
einmal viel anfälliger für krankheiten
aber warum ist das eigentlich so altern
ist eines der natürlichsten dinge die
wir tun es passiert uns ständig und
jeden tag und nicht nur menschen sondern
auch die allermeisten tiere altern aber
eher evolutionär gesehen ergibt das doch
nur wenig sinn oder das große ziel des
spiels dass sich evolution nennt ist am
leben zu bleiben und seine gene an die
nächste generation weiterzugeben
und diese beiden faktoren bestimmen wie
sich eine spezies fortpflanzt entweder
mit sehr vielen nachkommen und einen
dafür geringen lebensalter der einzelnen
lebewesen oder dem gegenteil lebewesen
die durchschnittlich extrem alt werden
dafür aber nur wenige nachkommen zeugen
und natürlich gibt es auch alle
möglichkeiten dazwischen aber diese
beiden faktoren sind normalerweise im
gleichgewicht eine theorie besagt dass
spezies die sowohl kurze generation
zyklen als auch eine lange lebensdauer
haben über population licon was oft dazu
führen kann dass mangelnde nahrung die
population wieder einschränkt kann es
also sein dass sich unser körper bewusst
irgendwann ausschaltet um platz für die
nächste generation zu machen
ein vorprogrammierter tote quasi ja
nichts anderes ist das altern auf eine
mikroskopischen level wir bestehen aus
zellen und die sterben irgendwann jede
sekunde sterben in deinem körper circa
zwei millionen zählen
aber es werden auch jede sekunde zwei
millionen neue zellen produziert sodass
du immer ungefähr gleich viele zellen im
körper hast
auf dauer führt das übrigens dazu dass
fast alle zellen des körpers
ausgetauscht werden und du zu einem
großen teil aus komplett anderen zellen
besteht als noch vor ein paar monaten
oder jahren
dazu habe ich aber schon ein video
gemacht das könnt ihr hier oben finden
das produzieren von neuen zellen macht
dein körper durch einen einfachen trick
zellteilung stadt komplett neue zellen
zu produzieren teilen sich die lebenden
zellen einfach auf das funktioniert für
eine weile lang super bis die grenze
erreicht ist
die hay flick grenze entdeckt 1961 von
lennart heflik einem gerontologen einem
alters wissenschaftler die hälfte grenze
beschreibt wie oft sich eine zelle
teilen kann
bevor der programmierte zelltod eintritt
und die ist bei menschen ungefähr bei 50
verantwortlich für dieses limit sind
telomere die enden von chromosomen denn
die werden bei jeder zellteilung etwas
kürzer bis sie schließlich nach circa 50
teilungen eine kritische länge
unterschreiten und so kurz sind dass
sich die zelle nicht mehr teilen kann
und abstirbt
obwohl diese entdeckung 1961 gemacht
wurde sind wissenschaftler immer noch
dabei den prozess des alterns auf den
grund zu gehen und ihn zu verstehen aber
es gibt bereits experimente die gezeigt
haben dass die telomere wieder
verlängert werden können was direkt dazu
führt dass sich die zellen weitaus
häufiger teilen können als nur 50 mal
könnt ihr das also das mittel sein das
den alterungsprozess stoppt und jedem
die eigene wahl gibt wann er stirbt nun
ja hier sollte man wirklich ganz
vorsichtig sein denn eine andere art von
zellen die sich auch unendlich oft
teilen können sind krebszellen die
tatsache dass sie keinen einen
programmierten zelltod haben und sich
immer weiter teilen können ist die
ursache dafür dass tumore erst entstehen
es kann also gut sein dass unser körper
ganz bewusst zellen irgendwann sterben
lässt nämlich damit sich fehlerhafte
zellen nicht weiter verbreiten können
und das ist super interessant denn genau
wie auf dem mikroskopischen level zellen
irgendwann sterben müssen machen ja auch
tiere irgendwann platz für die nächste
generation wir menschen wurden viele
tausend jahre lang im durchschnitt nur
circa 30 jahre alt
fortschritte in medizin und
nahrungsbeschaffung sorgten aber dafür
dass menschen vor 100 jahren circa 50
jahre alt wurden und heute liegt die
lebenserwartung für neugeborene in
entwickelten ländern bei über 80 jahren
mit dieser entwicklung geht zwar auch
eine senkung der geburtenrate einher
trotzdem ist die weltbevölkerung in den
letzten 100 jahren zahlenmäßig
explodiert die frage ist also was
passiert wenn die wissenschaft einen weg
findet telomere zu verlängern ohne dabei
das krebsrisiko zu steigern
was wenn wir ein effektives mittel gegen
das altwerden erfinden die folgen so
einer erfindung wenn sie nicht verboten
wird sind nur schwer abzuschätzen aber
als erstes werden natürlich weniger
menschen an altersschwäche sterben
das lässt die weltbevölkerung sehr
rapide ansteigen und zwingt viele länder
womöglich dazu dass zeugen von kindern
einzuschränken oder sogar zu verbieten
auf dauer dürften menschen nur dann ein
kind bekommen wenn vorher jemand stirbt
was dann nur noch durch sehr
schwerwiegende krankheiten passiert oder
wenn sich jemand bewusst dazu
entscheidet zu sterben
es würde riesig lange listen mit paaren
geführt werden wie alle eltern werden
wollen gleichzeitig müssen tausende
schulen und universitäten schließen weil
es kaum noch kinder gibt die ausgebildet
werden müssen
das legt den fokus vielmehr auf eine
individuelle erziehung und ausbildung
man kann kindern jetzt einen einzigen
persönlichen lehrer geben der sie dann
mit neuen aufgaben konfrontiert wenn es
der richtige zeitpunkt für sie ist und
nicht für die ganze klasse
wenn menschen mehrere hundert jahre alt
werden könnten sie viel effektiver in
ihren berufen arbeiten
die gesammelte erfahrung eines
menschenwürde nicht mehr nach weniger
als 50 jahren arbeit verloren gehen das
kann ein riesiges potenzial für den
fortschritt der menschheit bedeuten
trotzdem würden wahrscheinlich viele
leute hunger leiden müssen und es wurde
sogar kriege um ressourcen geben bis
sich die weltbevölkerung zahlenmäßig
angepasst hat und von da an
wer weiß wahrscheinlich besiedeln wir
den mars und danach andere planeten um
als menschheit zu wachsen
alles ist möglich auch dass unser system
unter der last so vieler menschen
zusammenbricht die frage ist nur wollen
wir das ist alter ein teil des lebens
und unseres lebenszyklus oder sollten
wir wie viele jetzt schon mein altern
als
und einstufen und versuchen diese zu
bekämpfen wie andere genetische
krankheiten auch die frage geht ich
jetzt einfach mal an euch weiter ist
altern eine krankheit diskutiert mit mir
und in den kommentaren wenn ich das
video gefallen hat vor allem einen make
up dann gib mir einen daumen nach oben
und wir sehen uns bis zum nächsten
donnerstag